[Musique]
du Pôle Sud au Pôle Nord dans chaque
petit P il est nul l'erreur pour bien
pêcher de bon pêcheurs on en trouve
partout jusque chez les Zoulous les plus
forts malgré tout ce sont ce de chez
nous les
Pescadou de la martiale sont de vieux
loups que rien égale ils iraient
n'importe où dans la rafale ce sont des
cass cou dans leur youou de la girè au
plus gros étoile dans leur filet il pr
le tout les
Pescadou de la marsale sont les plus
fort de tous les
pescadous quand ils quittent la mer en m
Tron de l'air il pêche au figuré pêché
c'est le mignon pêché un clin d'œil
polisson un seul coup d'ameçon et o ils
sont vainqueurs quand ils pêchent des
cœurs les
pesquou de la marciale grand méchant
loup de rien égale oui mais ils ont
surtout de N chigale le dou éclair bagou
les Pesti
qu dans les cœurs ils
fontescal ah les corsaires il for tout
les
P la
marale les rois voyez-vous des
[Musique]
Frot a des méridionaux dans la salle
ou et ben alors il faut
chanter vous promettez la prochaine vous
la chantez
hein très
fort je savais pas que c'était
marseillais
ça vous savez que plus marseillais que
les Marseillais il y a les Corses et
comme son nom ne l'indique pas Francis
Linel est un Corse de Marseille il
chante adieu Venise Provençale